en el último vídeo hablamos acerca de la
ley de la demanda y todo esto
significaba un cambio en el precio si el
precio subía entonces la cantidad de la
demanda iba hacia abajo mientras que el
precio bajaba entonces la cantidad de la
demanda subía entonces si todo se
mantiene igual setter ys paribus nos
estaríamos moviendo justo sobre esta
curva dependiendo en qué precio estamos
pero en el último vídeo también
empezamos a hablar sobre qué es lo que
pasaba si nosotros cambiamos algo acerca
de esta igualdad algo con respecto a la
demanda es decir con respecto al precio
o la cantidad demandada y nos
preguntábamos cómo es que cambie la
demanda si nosotros tenemos un cambio en
el último vídeo nosotros también
hablamos acerca del precio de los bienes
relacionados y si el precio de los
bienes relacionados cambiaban pero todo
lo demás se mantenía constante nosotros
hablábamos qué es lo que pasaba si
crecía o de crecía la demanda ahora
vamos a hablar acerca de otro de los
factores que manteníamos constante y
vamos a variar lo y este factor son los
cambios esperados
precios futuros lo que nosotros queremos
saber es cómo va a cambiar toda mi curva
de la demanda dados los cambios
esperados en los precios futuros así que
hablemos de un primer escenario que
tenemos aquí en el cual dada esta curva
de demanda la gente no espera que
cambien los precios de este libro
electrónico y de una manera repentina
cambian los precios en este libro
electrónico vamos a decir no sé que los
precios se elevan de una manera
inesperada por lo tanto ahora tengo que
la expectación de los precios futuros es
que suba el precio si tú esperas o
tienen las expectativas de que tu precio
futuro suba y estamos hablando acerca de
un bien o de un producto sea cual sea
pero que tú quieres comprar bueno
depende un poco de cuánto esperes que
sube el precio porque si tú esperas que
el precio va a subir pues seguramente lo
que te conviene es comprarlo justo ahora
antes de que el precio suba mucho más
así que veamos en cada uno de estos
puntos sin importar en qué punto este es
la gente como lo acaba ir corriendo a
comprar mi producto y por lo tanto para
cada punto
la curva de la demanda la cantidad
demandada va a aumentar así por ejemplo
si nosotros vendíamos a dos pesos la
cantidad de gente va a aumentar y
también para todos los demás precios
para cuatro seis ocho y diez pesos y
esto lo que quiere decir es que la curva
de la demanda va a desplazarse hacia la
derecha así que aquí tenemos la solución
del primer escenario y dependiendo de
cuánto cambia el precio pues va a ser
cuánto se va a recorrer hacia la derecha
nuestra curva de la demanda y bueno
entonces podemos concluir que en toda
esta curva lo que sucedió es que
incrementó la demanda la demanda
incrementa y ya sé que tal vez estés
hasta el cansancio de que te diga esto
pero estoy hablando no de una cantidad
particular estoy hablando acerca de toda
la curva entera y si te das cuenta que
es lo que sucedió fue que toda la curva
se recorrió hacia la derecha pues bueno
recuerda que lo que pasó fue que la
gente se puso como loca y quiso comprar
ese producto antes de que le subieran el
precio y bueno tal vez ya te puedas
imaginar qué es lo que va a pasar en el
segundo escenario así que tomémonos el
escenario número 2 y este escenario con
qué peculiaridad nos va
vamos a suponer que la gente estaba
neutral es decir que la gente estaba
sobre nuestra curva de la demanda
inicial y en este momento la gente se va
a enterar de que el precio en un futuro
va a bajar es decir el precio esperado
en un futuro se va a ir hacia abajo y
esto es justo lo que pasa con los
aparatos electrónicos y te das cuenta
cuando nosotros compramos una
computadora lo que suele pasar es que
después de un tiempo los precios bajan
muchas veces nosotros lo que esperamos
es que los precios bajen y tenemos una
idea de que el precio esperado va a
bajar pero bueno regresemos nosotros
estamos en un punto de neutral y de
repente nos enteramos que el precio del
producto que queremos comprar va a bajar
en un futuro así que si tú tienes un
cierto precio para comprar este producto
y tú sabes que en un futuro este precio
va a bajar por lo tanto en este momento
lo que va a suceder es que tú vas a
decir oye no yo creo que mejor me voy a
esperar algún tiempo para comprar este
producto porque el precio va a bajar
esto quiere decir que en este escenario
toda la curva se va a desplazar hacia la
izquierda o dicho de otra manera en
cualquier punto de esta curva de la
demanda la cantidad demandada
va a bajar por lo tanto vamos a
escribirlo aquí la demanda es la que va
a decrecer la demanda es la que decrece